[Musique]
on a long travail je leur mettait à
pleurer dans la voiture avant de rentrer
dans le régiment jeu sécher mes larmes
je rentrais dans le régiment et je
voulais montrer à personne cette
faiblesse qui pour moi est une faiblesse
n'est pas forcément une faiblesse mais
c'est comme ça que moi je la prends et
je voulais pas montrer ça aux gens
jusqu'au jour où on fait bas en fait à
une personne et du centre médical des
armées mais m'a aperçu sur ce parking en
train de pleurer dans mon véhicule qui
me connaissaient très bien qu'ils maliba
coutu avec moi tu m'entends selma est au
courant de tout mon histoire et de là on
fait un diagnostic et une très grosse
dépression suite se respecte on avait
honte par rapport à mes hommes ont par
rapport à mes chefs par rapport aux
institutions et on me par rapport à mes
valeurs
[Musique]
la névrose de guerre ça on la connaît
depuis depuis des siècles c'est aussi
lieu de la guerre est d'arriver à
expliquer aujourd'hui que c'est une
vraie blessure physiologique quelque
chose qui est nouveau et donc ça semble
important de l'expliquer de le dire
aussi pour que vous disiez voilà c'est
ok je suis blessé et donc moi je
m'explique aujourd'hui quand
j'interviens devant vos camarades qui
sont à gimont les chefs de corps les
criminels ont leur dire voilà il ya une
réalité de la blessure c'est une réalité
de la blessure c'est en fait le cortex
préfrontal un peu ne communique plus
avec la vidal pour lui dire calme toi
parce que à l'intérieur des choses qui
sont cassées et des chercheurs
néerlandais qui ont mis qui ont déjà au
scanner parce que là en france on ne
sait pas qui sera à passer tout un
régiment complet au scanner avant la
mission puis après autour émission il ya
des chercheurs néerlandais qu'ils ont
fait et qui ont mis en exergue plus que
sur les patients qui étaient atteints de
sp t il y avait ces lésions au scanner
tous vous dites c'est une marque de
faiblesse moi dans mon régiment entendre
qu'on n'a pas un os qui sort on est pas
on n'est pas blessé en fait aujourd'hui
c'est aussi pour ça que la dans l'étape
de la recherche
on est bien sûr une blessure il
[Musique]
je pensais que ça allait mieux et j'ai
retapé dans mes vidéos
la tournée gopro tout cela cela que ça a
craqué les médecins m'avaient dit écoute
une jambe on sait que ces trois mois
sauf que pour toi bon c'est pas quand la
durée il faut après pour leur éducation
m'a dit c'est pas parce que tu penses
que ça va mieux qu'il faut se remettre
dedans c'est pareil pour une fracture ou
et ses terrasses moi parce qu'on se sent
bien au pied en fait on des trois mois
de raids à une rééducation
donc on fait avec
j'aimerais bien que ça lui évite
marseille
[Musique]
mais non ça c'est plus dur camarades il
a plu n'a plus ce qui me manque c'est
l'esprit de corps quoi
esprit de groupe ça s'est perdu ses
pairs du gois
[Musique]
est-ce que ça vaudrait pas le coup de
venir à moi ici quoi enfin montagne quoi
quitter paris ou quitter tout ça les
médias comptoir un mois ici parce que ça
les médocs
s'il s'est tendue en fait supervision
j'analyse sous toit sera issu de la
gauche laïque zozos lyall la cnae la
télé le télésiège qui monte dans sa
valise tout en fait
j'ai été rapatrié sanitaire du mali je
vais examiner hallucinations visuelles
et auditives depuis un certain temps et
quand je suis rentré en france je devais
rentrer juste pour un check-up de quatre
jours au val de grâce à paris et mes
proches me disait petit à petit je
déclinais en fait j'étais 2g j'arrivais
jeter mais comme je suis là actuellement
et au bout d'un moment j'avais de plus
en plus de mal à marcher réfléchir
devenait très compliqué je me levais une
heure par jour j'arrivais faire
péniblement 2 3 trucs que je retournais
mme blanchet pas ce que c'était c'était
l'enfer
on n'en parle pas tant que ça dans mon
régiment et où on parle pas du tout
quand on a un blessé ou quoi ben on dit
voilà il allait il est blessé ou quoi et
puis après petit à petit on demande au
début des nouvelles puis de moins en
moins aujourd'hui complètement
je n'ai pas de couper les ponts j'ai pu
une nouvelle du jour au lendemain c'est
ça c'est qu'on veut pas voir on le sait
tous nés on veut pas longtemps
dans le climat c'est cet atelier n'en
est pas un mais c'est vraiment un point
de vue un point d'étape c'est pas un
atelier comme les autres avec insertion
avec les lionceaux se l'était d'ailleurs
c'est vraiment un entretien conduit de
manière à en tête à tête faire un point
précis du parcours du décès de toutes
les démarches administratives qui
affirme quand on est blessé en salle
ainsi les chercheurs
voilà je fais la version courte
la version courte c'est que j'étais au
déchocage on m'a demandé de me préparer
pour recevoir un grand moment de baisser
jusqu'à avec un médecin et est en fait
le d'après ce qu'on nous avait dit le
camp était attaquée donc on a récupéré
un mort de mort trois morts quatre morts
cinq voire six morts alors au bout de 8
1 et puis en fait on où il s'avèrerait
qu'en fait c'était un militaire de
l'armée nationale afghane qui s'étaient
levés pendant une réunion avec des
américains et qui leur avaient tiré une
balle dans la tête
un par un et qui avait marqué allahou
akbar sur les murs avec le sang des
victimes
et puis le soir ils ont décidé de nous
lâcher pour aller manger mais ils ont
fermé un des selfs sur les deux pour
intérêts interroger les afghans du camp
pour trouver deux talibans qui à priori
ce ballet l'encan et quand on est allé
manger le serveur à crier go out out
donc les américains ont paniqué ils ont
piétiné tout le monde et puis
les belges ont balancé une table pour se
protéger ils ont chargé leur pea et vont
pointer dans ma direction
et enfin je me suis retrouvée entre les
belges qui pointaient leur pea et quand
j'ai vu leurs regards qui avait la
panique et quoi je suis ça y est celle
des talibans grand cherche qui débarque
et qui vont nous canarder quoi je me
suis pas toute la boucherie qu'on a vu
toute la journée ben elle et pour nous
donc j'ai eu un moment dissociation ou
pas c'est ce que les psychiatres
appellent de la dissociation où je me
suis retrouvé à l'extérieur de mon corps
et où j'ai complètement été figé si
derrick et l'effroi le plus total donc
ça ça a été le premier traumatisme
puis on a eu plein d'autres à la mode et
de la tête aux pieds qu'on n'a pas pris
en charge parce que financièrement ça
riait trop coûteux donc on l'a renvoyé
dehors il était brûlé au troisième degré
la tête aux pieds
enfin des trucs comme ça quand un paquet
de trucs comme ça
[Musique]
je m'appelle testing et donc j'anime cet
atelier valeur et cv et on va attendre
commence à laquelle ils sont présents
par là maintenant la rare pour être moi
on va faire deux exercices qui vont
identifier
c'est une première identification ça
demanderait bien sûr plus de plus de
choses et plus d'exercices qu'on va
pouvoir faire par la suite
mais c'est une première identification
qui ont fait au crest battre qui a un
effet starter une première
identification de valeur alors il faut
savoir que dans quelques professionnels
l'engagement militaire ça demande un
certain nombre de valeurs parce qu'il ya
des valeurs militaires les valeurs
militaires judée et répertoriés et
hiérarchisés en fonction des
informations que j'ai récolté ses
intégrité courage loyauté altruisme
autodiscipline ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ça ce sont les valeurs militaires
et primauté de la communauté sur
l'individu donc mes informations sont
venus il ya un certain nombre de valeurs
qui sont répertoriés ici et vous ont
choisi ces sept qui vous correspondent
après ça on va réaliser votre cv le rôle
principal de série c'est qu'on va
transcrire votre expérience militaire
aux compétences civiles et lorsque vous
êtes lorsque vous avez un stress post
traumatique souvent vous perdez le sens
de ce qui s'est passé pour combien de
fois on entend je suis maire je suis
merde je comprends pas ce que j'ai fait
je comprends rien y'a pas de sens en bas
qu il n'y a pas de fil rouge
et quand on reprend le cv de façon
excessivement chronologique sein de
votre formation initiale et on remonte
et on remonte votre votre intégration
institutions militaires
permission vous allez voir qu'ils aient
un sens et par ailleurs vous allez voir
vous avez fait plein de choses c'est que
vous avez plein de compétences très moi
j'ai mis toute empathie compassion c'est
toi
ouais ouais partage simplicité et
sécurité financière
thain tyco chez toi dans la paperasse et
celle du couteau si simon a coché cette
famille une ouverture d'esprit
ouais respect des différences partage
empathie honnêteté discipline et rigueur
et qualité de vie innovation ben ça
c'est pareil c'est vaste est ce que
j'aime innové en jambe à innover non
j'aime ben non je sais que les valeurs
que j'avais avant l'opecst ce sont les
mêmes par contre elles sont moins fortes
quoi j'avais un attachement à l'armée
qui était sans conteste il aurait fallu
donner ma vie j'aurais donné ma vie
aujourd'hui c'est malheureusement plus
le cas parce que
f + et le sentiment que je devrais
peut-être pas dire ça mais j'ai le
sentiment d'être un peu lâché par par
l'armée par l'institution qui devait me
trouver un poste adapté et qui
finalement ne trouva rien quoi ai je
fait obligés de partir dans six villes
et ça je reviendrais à partir de l'armée
dans certains comme ça en fait je
n'avais jamais envisagé ce à quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était pas un gars très proche c'était
pas c'était un camarade quoi il a crevé
dans mes bras je lui mettais la main ici
ça ça puis c'est terrible il avait le
temps que je lui mette la main il avait
déjà perdu un litre
donc je sais pas si j'aurais pu faire
grand chose pour le sauver mais
disons que c'est moi qui lui ai demandé
de venir sur ma position m'appuyer pour
que pour que continue à avancer sur la
nuit j'ai beaucoup culpabilisé par
rapport à ça mais bon toute façon
aujourd'hui non parce que je me dis que
c'est le boulot donc
donc voilà où on a fait ce qu'il faut on
a enlevé le gie par balle mon pote on ya
fermer les paupières puis comme on
voulait pas le laisser là on a fait ce
qu'il faut pour le bouger on a bougé
qu'on l'a ramenée on l'a ramené à
l'hélico on l'a ramené en france on se
voyait pas le laisser laisser encore aux
mains de l'ennemi là ces pourritures ils
ont en effet des photos
enfin voila c'était quand même assez
éprouvant c'est tous chez dessus il y
avait mon chef de groupe avait déjà fait
la fga lui avait déjà été au feu pas mal
de fois ils avaient déjà tué il avait
déjà vu la mort tout le bruit j'ai eu de
la chance devriez de suite si on
accueille ivry plus tard moi j'ai varié
de suite quand je suis rentré ok on est
tous passés devant les docks mois les
documents divorce ils ont tout et toi tu
es en arrêt a foutu dirais six mois
hôpital psychiatrique à bordeaux
[Musique]
oui
il
je vous
[Musique]
bon bah on est à plus tard ouais je
redescendrai si je fais le point jusqu'à
novembre l'année dernière on fait
jusqu'à ce que je prenne des médicaments
c'était pas un acte sexuel entre
guillemets réglementaire et qu'ensuite
en a rendu compte quand j'en ai suis
rendu compte
voilà parce qu'en fait tout finale quand
j'ai eu la partie médicaments et puis
que j'ai voulu avoir un acte sexuel en
fait avec mon épouse est bien vu j'étais
plus adouci avec les médicaments
acceptera tout ça c'est là que je me
suis aperçu en fait que j'étais en train
de donner vraiment de l'amour j'en ai
sorti d'une cet après midi là une phrase
c'est j'épouse et les courbes c'est
vraiment le toucher les choses comme ça
etc
j'avais vraiment envie de faire l'amour
mais il s'avère que l'acte s'étendait
s'étendent et s'étendait s'étendait
s'étendent et puis moi je ne sentais pas
je je
là c'est la petite pointe qui te fait
monter puis qu'il dit ah ça va arriver
ça va arriver
rien rien et au bout d'un moment j'ai dû
m'arrêter et lui dire écoute je que je
peux pas je n'y arrive pas donc ben déjà
bas ça la fout dans un mauvais état
toi tu te sens qu'on tue rester plus
tard puis s'est aperçu le père patrick
pulh et tu n'en trouve plus âpre l envie
et puis après baptême plus trop le faire
prier le sujet de la masturbation la
masturbation ça même quand on est
essoufflé avec les gouttes de sueur et
c'est tout ça n'est rien
voilà donc au final bat abandonné ne
t'abandonne je dois faire en fait en
attaque
[Musique]
je me dis que c'est à cause de mes docs
ma femme elle a besoin de se sentir
désiré et moi aussi je veux dire simple
c'est important qui comme ce feeling et
du coup ça amène beaucoup de culpabilité
dans les deux sens et puis en fait moi
le l'homme sévices l'ars et je me suis
même pas rendu compte
serre que les jours passent et puis les
semaines puis et moi et tu te rends
compte que ça fait un mois deux mois
devrait atteindre 1 et que thor sont
même plus envie tellement ça te fout les
boules quoi ont-ils fait pour faire le
crazy non respect à tous et que tu veux
même les plus sûrs parce que c'est cette
sorte de titou enfants apprennent que tu
peux être que tu as fait ton bien là que
gésir on avait un objet causé saturant
le service quoi tu fais le voilà le
devoir conjugal si je puis dire
puis après quand j'ai arrêté médicaments
ça a été mieux petit à petit j'ai encore
des soucis maintenant eh bien j'ai des
gros soucis de précocité c'était super
qu'est-ce que j'ai jamais connu ça et du
coup c'est encore tôt en tant qu'homme
c'est là où ça tu attends dans ton truc
c'est que tu es tu satisfait plus ta
femme c'est terrible alors tu essaies de
tous les moyens que tu peux mais au bout
d'un moment ça pose quand même un
problème quoi dans ta tête tu n'es pas
bien t'es pas bien tout ça
mécanique ça je suis pas c'est sarkozy
parce que pour être bien dans ta tête tu
as besoin d'avoir une bonne grosse barre
des familles qui la bat de conforter de
te dire que c'est moi je sais que c'est
mon les tasses et les médicaments c'est
voilà je suis si c est toi tu des blasés
toi à naples avoir du plaisir tu vas me
dire ok mais moi je m'en fous mon
avantage c'est que moi je peux dire est
encore plus longtemps toi c'est celle
des bonbons si tu veux être un jour
historique c'est à dire ça peut durer
j'ai pleuré selinger toi si demain tu as
tu as eu démentent célibat tu as changé
de cow boy
ouais c'est ça oui c'est aussi wes brown
en vaut deux descentes et stéphane
stéphane lui il est
moi ça fait 18 ans elle épouse c'est pas
pareil et les sentiments sont pas
pareils petit jeu là bas ça fait cinq
ans tu vois une habitude citoyens elle
connaît sa fin et donc forcément quand
tu restes avec la même personne et que
tu as pu après les mêmes sensations et
de ben c'est sûr ça fait un choc
moi aussi j'ai une plage de oued et elle
se passer brême et essayent tout de même
c'est quoi les médocs déjà les médocs
moi ça m'a jamais donné envie de baiser
quoi j'ai voté les méthodes ancien
driver est pareil chantage violé minable
de quoi enfin c'est ce que je pense quoi
la baisse est quand même top quoi et
ouais moi ça amusant autour du mali où
il ya bien six mois tu vois qu'ici moi
où je n'avais pas du tout envie de
baiser quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je fume au bord des routes
[Musique]
j'attends d'abord on les voulait rouler
bouler oui non bonjour à tous pour ce
que j'ai pas vu ce matin avec moi on va
faire un atelier avec la méthode légaux
sirius plaie qu'est ce qui se passe en
fait quand on donne des briques et un
enfant et qu'est-ce qui se passe tout
d'abord il va se servir de ses deux
mains lorsqu'on se sert de cette demain
on va avoir la particularité de se
servir de ces deux hémisphères du
cerveau en même temps choses qu'on ne
fait pas pour réfléchir et là je vous
donne on va réfléchir écouter et parler
avec ses mains au départ à travers les
lego ce qui se passe d'autres dans la
tête d'un enfant c'est que du fait de la
frustration de ne pas avoir une quantité
astronomique de pièces mais il va
pouvoir innover il va pouvoir créer il
va aller chercher son imagination et la
frustration fait partie du processus et
à chaque fois on va avoir un temps où je
vais vous poser une question un temps
que vous allez construire un temps on va
partager partagée par nous et réfléchir
on va raconter une histoire
vous allez avoir dix minutes c'est quoi
l'amitié pour vous et vous pouvez
utiliser toutes les pièces que vous avez
devant vous celle que vous voulez autant
que vous voulez c'est quoi l'amitié pont
c'est parti
la sape le monde des bisounours
ok d'accord en fait dans quelles que
soient les différences j'en ai un cap
accord rien qu'à une couronne n'a qu'à
trois yeux quelles que soient les
différences de nationalité de race de
n'importe quoi on peut être amis et même
le même ce point de vue hiérarchique
soleil et en os mais finalement il est
avec les autres roquettes
et puis tout ça en vue d'être protégés
de se protéger les uns les autres
les difficultés de la vie quoi ok elle
ne concernait pas ça ces projets c'est
un environnement bienveillant une base
solide au début ça allait toujours
surtout quand on se rend compte qu'ils
partagent les mêmes choses comme elles
de choses puis on rajoute des éléments
dans la vie ça devient de plus en plus
fragile et à tout moment ça peut
s'effondrer et nous avec
ok et même si elles bases solides
on ne sait pas où
[Musique]
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8 pour accepter la
demande déjà ce qui est stupéfiant c'est
qu'on retient beaucoup plus facilement
les morts que les vivants le second à
quoi surprendre a réussi à ramener en
france
et quand je vois la liste cela je me dis
que pour quatre mois passés en
afghanistan elle est bien bien assez
longue
après y'en a un qui m'a particulièrement
marqué parce que la réanimation a été
très très longue
[Musique]
ça a duré plus de deux heures au final
il avait une balle dans la tête
donc on pouvait rien faire et j'ai un
sentiment d'échec parce que même si on a
fait tout ce qu'on a pu et qu'on pouvait
pas faire mieux et que je me dis voilà
les gars ils sont quand même partie sur
le terrain tout en sachant qu'il ya une
couverture militaires et sanitaires
derrière et ça suffit par an
sam sur anin est une des crêtes
on a déjà noté nos murs de combat on
sait qu'on va y passer la nuit donc on a
fait des zones d'installation avec des
murs suffisamment haut pour s'y allonger
être protégés au minimum de tout éclat
de roquette toute chose comme ça de tir
fusant dans la radio de jado section qui
lui n'a pas le même angle de vue que moi
qui n'est pas présent sur place donc je
lui en veux pas j'admets qu'il n'a pas
le même angle de vue mais il me demande
de remonter les murs car sur sa position
les murs ne sont pas suffisamment haut
et je lui dis que les biens sophie
suffisamment au jeu rift lors une
première fois je me ferai remonter à le
vendre à la radio forcément énormément
de monde à la radio donc déjà c'est déjà
bien vexant je sais qu'il y avait
quelque chose
mes hommes ont compris la radio nous ont
pas la radio me contre n on dirait la
chose et jérôme ans me regarder et
ligier formant d'aylmer si je suis
désolé les gars mais oui pas sa peine sa
bure ramassé une pierre écrit ou dit
plus on croit qu'ils pètent les plombs
ce qui m'est complètement ceinture on se
regarde tout ce qui lui arrive qui
s'écrit beau monde au dos sont au sol
c'est là qu'on comprend on nous apprend
dès qu'il ya un gros écoulement de sang
ce démarrage et donc les premiers et
seconds fait rien pour forcer en
appuyant c'est là qu'on aperçoit la
grèce sortir si de couleur jaunâtre se
sont donnés ci va mourir je suis obligé
de lui mentir parce que je suis pas dieu
je suis pas médecin
près ce qui s'en suivent c'est pas dur
sur intensification des feux en dégager
la personne obligée de descendre de sang
le mouvement de terrain j'essaie de le
porter et puis on le voit partir 30
d'appui de noël sa photo en français
pendant le reste de la mission
comme je l'avais dit on avait passé la
nuit peut-être deux trois jours après en
fait on apprend qu'en fait il est rentré
en france et que bon tout va bien pour
lui quoi et mais sommes individuellement
peut-être était prêt au sacrifice ultime
j'étais pas près autant de
responsabilités quand on est que ces
faits blessé quand l'autre a pris la
requête par rapport à ce mur et ses
responsabilités en fait au final c'est
que la culpabilité après c'est on
exprime beaucoup de culpabilité
on s'en veut et je suis même capable de
dire si j'aurais bien aimé l'apprendre à
sa place
je me compare à mon grand père qu a
perdu c'est pas une trentaine de potes
et je veux dire quoi moi je suis une
mère d'un côté nuit maintenant je suis
pas une merde moi j'ai fait mon taf il a
fait son taf et toi tu as fait ton taf à
tous les montages et on l'a bien fait on
a souffert des horreurs de dans la
souffrance est finie la souffrance est
finie moi j'étais juste de caporal voit
jeter tgv toi tu étais chef de groupe
note a commandé un groupe au combat quoi
on va venir que tu avais pas d épaules
parce que c'est pas vrai des écoles tu
les as carisa parce que pour commander
un pur commande un groupe au combat il
faut avoir des épaules
déjà pour être militaire fort des
épaules elle remplace pour un chef de
groupe
tu les as les épaules c'est tout le
maitien disait pas pourquoi mais
pourquoi j'ai fait le mali s'est collé
de chance quand je t'ai chat de groupe
la différence c'est que ce qui me donner
la force était méga maintenant
d'annoncer à toi et j'ai pris mes gars
j'ai pu mais mais mais caporaux et me
enfin tous acceptent accepte tout ce qui
c'était et qui me disait a dit serge ans
était cité pas devant nous on est on est
pas on te suit pas c'est ça qui me
donnait ma force
bonjour je te comprends j'ai ramené mon
pote il restait encore des méchants a
buté il restait abu zayd
ce jour là il y avait à vous à idées
dans le vainqueur moi j'aurais voulu à
une et camionnettes baïonnette au
canon et on l'a pas fait et je m'en suis
voulu pour ça je me suis je suis une
merde parce qu'on aurait dû aller tous
les buts et j'ai ramené le corps de mon
poids de gier
on est le court à sa famille tu
m'envoies la bio c'est le temps pour
nous reste qu'à ramener tous les mecs de
ton groupe du tour moi ça c'était mon
maître mot d'ordre michael bay alors
glané tous les mecs de tomberont coup et
puis d'un message
c'est énorme tu dis que tu as pas d paul
tu te faisais tu mets un peu je
trouve pas ce que tu as ramené tout le
monde à un bonhomme je pense être à
l'antenne
[Musique]
flex important c'est très petit cerveau
devrait d'abord aller voir avoir six
points avance normalement un
commencement mais parce qu'avec les
traitements
[Musique]
on rappelle la dgs à cet appareil en
plein comme ça avec des montagnes
t'as ton instinct qui disent regardez à
tous les points clés mais mais c'est
apaisant parce que je fais des animaux
et c'est un bon facteur pour te dire
s'il ya du danger ou pas même le vélo ça
rappelle un peu les convois plus con et
voilà mais c'est de garder en visu celui
devant cette dernière communication et
dans un autre contexte on a encore ses
automatismes qui reste 17 pas perdre le
groupe 2 on essaie de voir les choses
autrement en disant c'est pas grave au
pire je ne vois pas il n'est pas
dangereux
saran bouquet plus recette c'est dire
[Musique]
tu es mais c'est pas pu hollande ici que
des papillons partout des
talibans et là on est mal mon gars je te
dire une cuvette
voilà ils sont au dessus sur ses pas
très bon de s'arrêter là on va se
prendre une embuscade là on est dans une
cuvette les modes de contact pagola
contact arrière certains camarades qui
disent ouais mais les autres ils
comprennent pas et forcément qui
comprennent pas ils n'ont pas vécu là tu
peux tu peux échanger d'autres choses
avec eux quoi déjà en traçant les gens
comprennent ce qu'ils ont envie mais bon
il faut pas faut pas rester seul faux
pas ce faut pas s'enfermer sait pas
quand tu plan vert je pense qu'à ça tu
picole
c'est pas du tout à vis et deviens un
peu haché quoi ouais ouais
les psychologues surtout surtout rhône
arrive vraiment aidé quoi vraiment aidé
une donner des pistes à chaque fois tu
as essayé ça machin à chaque fois que
j'ai à chaque fois que j'ai eu un
entretien avec lui mais c'était génial
je sortais de là avec une patate
j'avais envie de reprendre des
d'entreprendre des trucs gros premier
truc en main donc vraiment cool merci à
l'armée française quand même de d'avoir
mis tout ça en place ça n'a pas toujours
été le cas
quand je sais quand je disais tout à
l'heure la toute ma famille a été blessé
de guerre
le grand père la grande peur et de
l'arrière grand père ils ont réélu qu'il
n'y avait pas de petits et pas deux
y'a aucun droit quoi mon grand-père lui
à la haine contre l'armée française
parce qu'ils ont complètement abandonné
quand il s'est quand même battus pour la
france et c'était son pays et où il a
été blessé et il est passé plus enfants
commission pensions militaires
d'invalidité devant des petits des
petites aux cards officiers qui sont
jamais partis et qui lui disait qu'il
avait rien fait alors qu'il a fait deux
ans d'algérie a été baissée quoi il
tempéré
ouais bah mon grand père m'a tout
raconté mon grand père a vécu toute sa
vie en est à treize post traumatique
j'en avais pas conscience à l'époque
mais là depuis que depuis que ça m'a
touché mon web en grand péril mon
grand-père 60 ans après on en constant
dans 60
ouais 50 ans quasiment 60 ans quoi
quasiment 60 ans après il fait encore
des cauchemars quoi tu te retrouve chez
lui il est qu'on peut m'en rends pas
complètement des tatras post traumatique
et toute sa vie il a parlé que de
l'alger ya que l'algérie quoi et que la
guerre d'algérie ça c'est des fois ils
m'appellent la nuit en pleurs skieront
fait des rêves il a vécu des trucs dont
on ne parlait pas ou un truc der kwast
des trucs vraiment salaces quoi et voilà
mais bien sûr on n'est pas on n'est pas
des robots
mon mari la trompe at il a crevé là dans
mes bras là j'avoue j'étais grange était
rempli de samba pendant dix jours déjà
le temps de finir la mission tu vraiment
pas changé de tri j'avais j'avais du
sang partout tu vois les sens à sa
future et un privé ça m'est arrivé la
nuit quand je ne rêvais de faire des
cauchemars je sentais du comme si
j'étais rempli de 100 kw à l'eau dame
qui était plus basse en six mois un an
ça me le faisait ça t'arrive est un
genre de devoir allumer les lumières
pour vérifier qu'il était bien chez toi
ouais je faisais des idées chez mes
parents je faisais des rondes la nuit en
machette
en plus mes parents il habite juste à
côté de 5e rhc tata les hélicos qui
passe toute la nuit et encore ils font
des manifs de nuit passe juste au dessus
me michael là et toutes les nuits
étaient en train de faire des cauchemars
tu as les hélicos qui passe en nouvelle
zélande
quand je suis arrivé dans les bacs
pâques en fête ebakpak seller des
endroits où tous les étudiants ou les
travailleurs à l'étranger deviennent en
nouvelle zélande bosser en fait ils sont
quatre ou cinq dans la même pièce
quand je suis rentré dedans en fait il y
avait la même odeur que dans les maisons
afghanes est exactement la moder quand
je suis entré jazz chez moi non voilà je
peux pas rentrer et si les petits
détails et à chaque fois face à tous les
petits coups de rappel mais moi c'est un
peu comme accroche sur la maison c'est
plutôt quand je sais que je dois les
faire et pas j'adore ça aussi ça tiens
ça va bien passé aussi les courses
ouais je l'aimé ce qui m'agace
moi c'est surtout quand on va voir les
psychologues et les psychiatres appui
qui nous pose la question vous allez
faire les courses
oui mais si moi faut mais je le fasse
par obligation j'ai toute une famille à
nourrir etc
faut bien aller faire les courses soit
bref c'est toi dans le drive tu ne
trouves pas tous les produits que tu
peux avoir dans un magasin je suis
complètement d'accord à mais c'est un
bon palliatif pour éviter les grosses
grosses surfaces ou moi c'est mort tu
vois ses produits aux négociations
sociales à l'ouverture oui valais
l'ouverture à la fermeture royal aux
ouvertures j'y vais une demi-heure avant
la fin on va dire que je vais y aller
demain
ouais si demain je ne sens pas je n'y
vais pas souvent sous la tente 24 48 72
heures quand je me sentirai bien d'y
aller bien sûr qu'il faut un petit
parking où il a ou le sait pas je serai
pas opressé où je serai pas là autre
endroit de rencontres et des regards
c'est là où je ne rencontrerai pas des
gens avec un certain code vestimentaire
qui fera penser à l'afghanistan mais
simplement le fait d'y aller d'y être
allé dans la journée vous aurez accumulé
du stress pendant ce déplacement etc
au final le soir je devrais pas dormir
ouais d'accord par ici nous allons en
ville ne serait ce que pour faire aller
le titien l'ophtalmo bourg négoce et
cetera aller voir un médecin qui s'est
passé exactement la même chose
alors là le pire c'est que ça rendez
vous obligatoire donc tu es forcément
obligé d'y aller que tu te sens tu te
sens tu pas tutoyer paf qui rencontre la
population et c'est tout ça à le soir
c'est moi laissez le parti attend mais
pas dormir moi je m'apercevais au bout
d'un moment qu'il fallait peut-être que
j'aille me coucher parce que voilà que
tu vas te coucher l'épreuve j'ai une
question tu as une voiture qu'est ça te
fait quand tu dois prendre la voiture
elle et faire des trajets est ce que tu
as des sensations outre non je me sens
chez moi dans la voiture je me sens chez
moi je me sens vraiment à l'aise et se
passe très bien
maintenant sur le trajet je te cache pas
les choses c'est que c'est vrai le
comportement m'énerver la ouais je monte
en tension d'eon je serai capable de
sortir de la bagnole d'attraper le mec
etc
mais heureusement tu as une partie enfin
j'ai une partie de moi-même
qui dit que ben faut pas le faire parce
que tu on va se tirer d onde va
s'attirer des ennuis mais j'ai vraiment
envie de le faire et du coup bah tu
prends tu prends tu prends tu prends tu
te ment et c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui je suis aussi stressé et
à fleur de peau c'est parce qu'en fait
c'est j'ai tellement magasiner et je
continue emmagasiné je sais pas on va
dire que pour l'instant j'ai la chance
de ne pas avoir frappé
ma femme j'en ai connu et des yeux nous
sommes arrivés sur l'autoroute mois un
gars qui me suivait de trop près quand
je vivais c'est beaucoup trop peu il m'a
fait des appels de phare ça m'a
tellement tellement énervée enfin nrd
suis dit le médecin ou faudrait
comme une balle dvc passé à apparaître
en furie je vais rattraper et là je le
connais mais je te jure j'étais à deux
centimètres de sa bagnole à l'arrière
sur la voie de gauche
on roulait à 200 mètres à chercher dans
les skis volontairement tu savais que
j'allais je voulais en l'air
parce que c'est un ange et les mecs
voilà tu peux toucher les gens comme
s'ils voulaient me tuer quake3 joubert à
ce moment là c'est ok donné le danger
qu'elle gêne tout le temps peine il doit
venir mais je veux dire par là c'est un
danger qui participent chaque juge le
but tout en danger en danger en moi
j'étais mis sur la défensive moi je te
comprends le carrément moi je te vois
monter convoi tu devras l'aîné le même
genre de réaction donc ça vient de ça
j'ai vu légiférer si je me dis mais
c'est bien le sens une fois le convoi en
tête de que dans un gain des tétées
commun comme une furie derrière la latte
à plat en train de foot de coups de
laser des coups de laser pour prévenir
prévenir à léonie shot et tout pour tu
sens que ça devient tendu et encore tu
dis ouah michotte s'est passé de la
connerie ça aussi un as tu rigole mais
excusez moi mais moi je n'ai pas fait un
seul avant de trouver quand à parier ou
n'importe quoi c'est de la grosse
connerie pourquoi pas ce qui est bien
faite au final c'est cap atterri sur une
famille on apporter quoi et c'est quand
tu te retrouves en arrivant sur kaboul
et toute la circulation est présenté
tout bas tu préfères tu choisis d'accord
je peux pas te permettre un jour du
véhicule qui arrivait enfin les
véhicules est arrivée dans nos sociétés
sont bas côté ils savent qu'il faut pas
bouger quand on circule ils
savent le savent très bien
eh ben il ya un véhicule et d'où ils le
savent pas ces marqueurs la race est
marqué par tous le savent et les loups
douce et marquer dismoioù c'est que
c'était marqué dans ce que la route
ils sont chez eux c'est nous qui sommes
arrivés qui avoir imposé la chose que
vous ne relève le problème c'est qu on a
pas à dire qu' on n'a pas investi un
pays en leur disant écoutez maintenant
vos hôtels vous appartiennent plus on
fera ce qu'on veut y croire
on est d'accord mais le problème c'est
le problème il est pas là le problème si
j'aurais dû te flinguer le mec avec dans
sa bagnole
je regrette aujourd'hui d'avoir fait la
piste pour ma famille je regrette de
l'avoir fait bien souvent quand je pars
un peu dans mes pensées et ses deux fils
et tous partout et ce petit bout de chou
qui vient côté hockey team to speech a
pas ça va j'ai pris une grosse part de
trouille de tout ceci pied le sujet
sourit et puis j'ai fait une petite
thérèse sur la tête parce que bah en
fait ils viennent l'aider parce que il
m'a sorti du contexte
mais il sait il sait pourquoi donc c'est
pour ça qu'il vient comme ça et puis qui
me posent cette petite question pour
pouvoir me sortir imed l'hymne apporte
une aide en tout cas moi c'est comme ça
que je le prends et je sais qu'il le
fait lui-même et m'a jamais posé de
questions parle pas ce qui s'est déroulé
là bas et il le fera plus tard entre
cadeaux mais aujourd'hui il sait que son
papa et je veux dire tout le monde en
parle la commande le terme blessure pour
le sp tb pour lui je suis malade
une petite anecdote pour tout ceci ce
qu'un jour mon épouse savaient que je
picole et quand j'étais au boulot et
elle savait que j'allais accepté en fait
quand elle m'a posé la question de nous
demander de passe au val d'or donc j'y
suis allé j'ai ramené ce mcdo
certes dans une hta de conduite que
j'aurais qui n'était pas autorisée mais
je suis quand même rentrer chez moi sans
avoir provoqué d'accident et j'ai servi
ce mcdo sur la table et tout le monde a
mangé
j'étais tellement bourré je me sens
dormir la tête d'une sonde which dont le
remet au regard des enfants qui se
foutait de ma gueule qui ont pris les
photos etc
quelle image quelle image
si ma famille ne peut pas vivre
correctement
par rapport à ma présence quitte à
laisser un héritage par rapport aux
assurances à la prévoyance
quitte à mambé est une page même si je
perds ma famille parce que le fameux kit
jura avec quoi attendre mes études
[Musique]
du cardio 10 secondes allez allez même
si l'info il en reste deux à faire c'est
pas grave
chaque époque c'est une récompense sa
crise
c'est bon pour boire un coup
vous allez construire ce que vous
retenez des jeunes de cet atelier que
vous retenez le stage ducret battre qui
vous qui vous sera nécessaire pour aller
plus loin dans vos objectifs vos projets
et là je vous laisse dix minutes
reconstruire avant qu'on partage enfants
est partie l'arabe ou le sachet mais tes
mains dans les lego
[Applaudissements]
j'ai représenté un petit bonhomme avec
un pied levé suite j'élargis j'ai mis
deux yeux tournés vers l'avant plus
large parce qu'il a une vision qui la
vivent plus large
il sait y va et il a des obstacles
devant lui mais ces obstacles sont
transparents maintenant c'est plus
vraiment d des obstacles dont keith et
des voix derrière les derbys ben espèce
d'énorme fardeau mais qui n'est pas
rattachée à vie qui reste derrière donc
c'est derrière vie ça se passait et on
voit un mail tourner vers l'arrière avec
un type l'ovaire qui qui symbolise en
fait un regard positif sur sur le passé
ok merci aux commerçants
ce que je retiens du crédoc cette
semaine là et de ce que j'attends du
crest date pour l'avenir et de ce que
j'ai besoin parce qu'aujourd'hui je ne
peux pas faire ça seul c'est d'un
accompagnement pouvoir gravir ces étapes
et mam nay où triomphe
ok c'est pour ça que la base est
représentée ici car pour l'instant il
n'y a pas de base
tout est fébrile n'insistez pas
soudain tac loire c'est qu'on se base de
l'âme et de sougé mimi des plaques
rouges ça représente
ça représente tout le sang qui a coulé
que j'ai plus envie de voir couler après
j'y vais j'ai mis du verre parce que moi
j'ai besoin j'ai besoin de la nature je
vous aime j'ai bien des espaces là j'ai
mis un petit pont avec une rivière ce
que je pense que la plupart de mon temps
au bord de la rivière
à méditer à pêcher avec mon petit plomb
ça c'est ma mère il sera toujours là
quoi j'ai besoin aussi et ça me rassure
ça c'est leur os c'est l'amour voilà
j'ai bien j'ai besoin d'amour je viens
d'en donner
et là c'est moi qui prends mon envol
voilà je suis chiant ce que j'ai fait
j'ai bien bossé voilages et j'en suis là
aujourd'hui
donc c'est un peu je sais pas comment
dire ça mais drapeau ok voilà pour
parcours d'ici ce qu'il faisait face et
en quoi le sport ça c'est clair
d'accord j'ai de la chance de rencontrer
les gens ici qui vont aider à reprendre
posséderait et puisqu'elle ludique de
tout ça vous fout je viens m puis après
ben faut que j'accepte quitter l'armée
et puis de voir vers l'avant avec une
passerelle est rogers avec une
passerelle pour convertir tout ce qui
est militaire ou civil du pommeau et
puis c'est d'aller de l'avant
[Musique]
alors on va ouvrir on va se on va se
mettre face à face à la montagne un
ouvrant le cercle est ce que reste eu
lieu l'idée encore un ce symbole c'est
que avec ce drapeau qui ajoute qu on
vous lâche pas et bien très nettement
c'est que vous voyez la montagne c'est
autant de chemins possibles
autant d'objectifs possible alors c'est
pas la montagne c'est compliqué c'est
dur et des objectifs il ya des obstacles
à surmonter
et voilà grâce aux clés aux outils qu'on
vous a donné cette semaine d'un il faut
essayer de les surmonter pour atteindre
vos objectifs et le sommet que l'on sait
alors on accueille votre et totem votre
totem va vous accompagner le parcours
propose maintenant
[Musique]
j'en ressors quel point ils baissent
quand même ce pas là
etc
[Musique]
à trois jours
c'est tout
[Musique]
c'est bon ça
humour
[Musique]